dr. deborah birx is in the white house
she's at the coronavirus response
coordinator working on this pandemic dr.
Burks it's very good to see you listen I
think many people were very relieved
that the president decided to extend the
deadline what exactly did you all see
that made you know that listen April
while it may have been aspirational
Easter it was not a good idea so what
are you seeing that convinced him to
extend it well we're constantly
integrating data from the global
pandemic as well as what's happening in
the United States and we can see in
Italy that as you flatten the curve the
duration at the top of the peak
lengthens also and so we can really
project as best we can about what's
happening in New York to the rest of the
country certainly we're hoping that
there aren't more New York cities and
New York metro areas around the country
but we have to plan for that and we have
to really tell the American people that
they have to do more to stay inside to
wash their hands to social distance and
to assume that other people are infected
even if they look asymptomatic so doctor
what exactly do you need to see because
it's gone from mid-april to now the end
of April what exactly do you all need to
see that we'll let you know it's okay to
lift social distancing so by the time
you're seeing cases in the hospital we
believe that it has gone from five to
fifty to five hundred to five thousand
and potentially even 50,000 that's the
part we don't know how many a sim not
innt asymptomatic mild cases are there
to every hospitalization case and that's
what we're going to be working on in the
rest of the country that doesn't have
these huge Metro hotspots to be able to
do surveillance at the same time we're
supporting the metro areas and other
areas to do full diagnosis and treatment
you know we keep emphasizing social
distancing a lot of people still are not
getting this memo they're still on the
beach over the weekend we saw churches
in Florida where the ministers were
saying we're not going to be intimidated
they're shaking hands the congregation
is shoulder to shoulder do you think we
have to have an official federal mandate
because just asking people does not seem
to be
working in many places well I think that
presidents made it clear what the
guidelines are and the expectation that
every state and local government will
look at this closely and do two things
ensure that that's applying to their
population and secondly prepare every
region every county every hospital for a
contingency plan if they get this kind
of doubling of five 250 to 500 to 5,000
to 50,000 we want every place in the
United States prepared for that so it's
a critical that even if you don't see it
it could be circulating in your
community
the president also still seems to be
questioning the requests for the number
of masks and the number of ventilators
we just heard him saying we just piece
it goes from 10 to 20 to 300,000 he says
where are all the masks going
are you questioning what the hospitals
are saying that they need I think what's
really important here is to look at all
aspects of the supply chain what does
each hospital have and how are they
being supplied are they being supplied
by the private sector or are they
relying on the pre movement of the
stockpile that went into warehouses it
doesn't help any of us and I know
everyone realizes that to have supplies
there and not reaching the hospital and
I think that's the piece we we have to
get that piece right and we're looking
to make sure that the hospitals are too
busy to define what they need it is our
job collectively the state and local
governments along with us to ensure that
the hospitals are receiving the supplies
they need is it concerning to you though
that the president seems to doubt what
governors are telling them that they
need I think we're watching every single
piece of data extraordinarily carefully
and we'll be able when this is over
we'll be able to really have a flu
pandemic plan that really takes all of
this into account where we can actually
predict what the needs were I mean the
stockpile was created to predict what
the extra need was clearly there wasn't
enough in the stockpile to really meet
the needs of all of America and so
really increasing the manufacturing what
does that has happened and make sure
that from manufacturing to hospitals
that this is happy
that hospitals are getting what they
need and that's what we're working on
every day all right dr. deborah birx we
all know this is all hands on deck we
thank you very much for your time